Conan, you're coming to Los Angeles,
and they're building your
studio in Universal City.
A bleak pit of despair,
that will crush your soul daily.
(audience laughter)
And, to get away from that and rejuvenate,
you're gonna wanna come here,
to sunny Burbank, California.
(upbeat music)
Conan, you're such a history buff,
we all know that,
and to scratch that itch,
you're gonna wanna come here,
to the Burbank Historical Society.
I'm in front of the Mentzer House,
this was built in 1887,
a year before the Jack The Ripper murders,
five years before the Beatles first L.P.
(audience laughter)
So, let's go inside and
let's learn about Burbank.
So, I'm talking to Mary Jane Strickland,
who is the founder of the
Burbank Historical Society.
You know Burbank inside and out,
so what I'm wondering is,
you know, Conan O'Brien has
a very distinctive look,
I mean, some would say compelling,
some would say freakish,
(audience laughter)
he has very, very distinct hair,
and I'm just wondering will
the residents of Burbank
kind of embrace that?
Like, have they seen
anything like that before?
Would they be okay with him?
What do you think?
Yeah, we have a lot of people with
funny hairdos in Burbank,
(audience laughter)
and we think he's very handsome.
Oh, nice.
Yes.
So, people in Burbank find Conan,
that's good to know.
Yes.
(audience laughter)
Nice.
Conan, I'm standing next to a Holy relic.
This is the jacket of Johnny Carson.
Some day, if you shrink eight inches,
and gain some talent,
(audience laughter)
this will adorn your torso.
Oh, it burns.
(audience laughter)
It burns.
Hi, I'm in a recreation
of a 1900's Burbank home.
I am here in my parlor,
(audience laughter)
with my wife, Opal,
who has gone insane.
(audience laughter)
Opal?
Opal, I know you can hear me.
(audience laughter)
We're gonna take you to the
nervous hospital now, Opal.
(audience laughter)
You'll stop seeing those laughing ghosts,
that force you to draw pictures
of swords that look like penises.
Opal!
(audience laughter)
(disembodied scream)
(scary music)
By the way, I just wanted
you guys to see this.
When you shoot stuff in L.A.,
even if it's something stupid,
like what we're doing right now,
they assign you a cop.
A cop has to be there for security,
look who they gave me.
They gave me a friggen superhero.
Look at this guy!
(audience laughter)
What's your first name?
Gammer.
Gammer?
Yes, sir.
More like, you know what?
Gammer-Man,
that's who they assigned to me,
Gammer-Man.
He's made of pure quartz and tornadoes.
(audience laughter)
He's made of five tornadoes,
Good God in Heaven.
My pleasure, sir.
No, hey, my pleasure.
(audience laughter)
(quirky music)
And, there's so many great
business names here in Burbank,
like, Hollywoof Dog Grooming,
Hair To Please,
Victorian Hairitage.
And, don't forget the business names that
sound great when said by Jerry Lewis,
like, Delsen Building,
Boysen Plaza,
(audience laughter)
Chadaka Thai,
and Old Navy!
(audience laughter)
This is Kerry Hite,
she's the owner of the
Wax Poetic Beauty Salon
right here in Burbank,
where I come to get my hair done.
Uhhh, uhhh, uhhh.
(audience laughter)
Wax Poetic, Conan, is where you can come
and not only get your hair done,
you can read a book.
Uh oh, Britney.
You can look at art.
Admire.
But, you know what?
Why should I talk about
it when I can show you
what a day at Wax Poetic Salon looks like.
Lets go check it out.
(relaxing music)
Hmm.
(screams)
(moaning)
(screams expletive)
(audience laughter)
Do you like paintings by serial killers?
Then come next door to Hyaena.
And nothing says John Wayne Gacy
like a clown in a graveyard,
and at Hyaena,
you can get all kinds of decorations for
Christmas.
(audience laughter)
Easter.
First Communion.
(audience laughter)
Hanukkah.
Oh my goodness,
I just finished another
delicious lunch here,
at the Olives Bistro,
inside The Coast Hotel,
but what made this lunch pretty amazing
was that I was served by
the restaurant's manager,
Rob Lambaren,
better known as,
Rawbzilla, competitive breakdancer.
You're a competitive break dancer?
Yeah.
And, you're world class?
Yes.
You go up against Germans, Czechs,
Chinese, and Russians?
Everything, yeah.
You take 'em all on?
Mm-hmm.
17 years?
17 years, yeah.
17 years, and so you manage
the restaurant to pay for
the break dancing?
Yeah.
That is dedication.
If you don't mind,
I'm going to finish my coffee,
and you're gonna bust some moves.
It helps with my digestion.
Yes, sir.
(funky music)
Glorious.
Well, it's been an amazing
day here in Burbank,
I'll bet you can't wait to get here.
It's time for me to scoot.
Gammer, let's go home.
(audience laughter and applause)